- [Instructor] What we're
going to do in this video
is give ourselves a little bit of a tour
of eukaryotic cells.
And the first place to start
is just to remind ourselves
what it means for a cell to be eukaryotic.
It means that inside the cell,
there are membrane-bound organelles.
Now, what does that mean?
Well, you could view it as
sub-compartments within the cell.
Membrane-bound organelles.
And in this video in particular,
we're going to highlight
some of these membrane-bound organelles
that make the cells eukaryotic.
So let's just start with
some of the ingredients
that we know is true of all cells.
So you'll have your
cellular membrane here.
I drew it big, so that
we have a lot of space
to draw things in.
So this is our cellular membrane.
I'll do some nice shading
so you appreciate that it'll
actually be three-dimensional.
We see so many slices of cells
that sometimes we forget
that they are more spherical,
or that they have
three-dimensional shape to them.
They're not all spherical.
They can have different shapes.
Now all cells, and there
are some exceptions
that we've talked about
in previous videos.
I should say, most cells
will have some genetic information in them
in the form of DNA.
So that is our DNA, right over there.
Now, one of the key characteristics
of a eukaryotic cell
is that the genetic information
is going to be inside a
membrane-bound organelle.
And that membrane-bound organelle,
or the membrane that
surrounds the DNA here,
that is the nuclear membrane.
So let me draw the nuclear
membrane right over here,
and I'll put some shading
in to appreciate that that
also is going to be in three
dimensions, around the DNA.
So that is the first
membrane-bound organelle
that we're gonna discuss, the nucleus.
Now the nucleus, it turns out,
is connected to another
membrane-bound organelle.
And we're gonna study
this in future videos,
but right here I'm drawing holes or pores
in the nuclear membrane.
And those pores connect to something,
it's a very fancy word called
the endoplasmic reticulum.
And the endoplasmic reticulum
is essentially these
layers of these membranes.
So I'm gonna do my best job
at trying to draw an
endoplasmic reticulum.
Imagine extending from these pores,
going into a space that has
really these layered membranes
that have a lot of surface area.
And I'm not gonna go all
the way around this nucleus,
but in many cells it will go around,
all the way around the nucleus.
And this right over here, and
this is just a rough diagram.
That is our endoplasmic, endoplasmic...
Not blasmic, endoplasmic...
Endoplasmic reticulum,
which I've mentioned in previous videos
would be an excellent name for a band.
And what goes on in the
endoplasmic reticulum
is when you are in the process
of taking that genetic
information from DNA,
and as we talk about in other videos
it gets transcribed into mRNA.
So that mRNA is now
containing that information.
That mRNA will make its way
out of that nuclear membrane
through one of these pores,
and then make its way to a ribosome
that is attached to the membrane
of the endoplasmic reticulum.
And so that's a ribosome there.
I'm gonna do a bunch of ribosomes.
And so as we've talked
about in previous videos,
ribosomes are really where you take
that genetic information from that mRNA,
and then you translate it into a protein.
So the ribosomes are
the protein synthesis,
so let me label that.
So this right over here is a ribosome.
And some ribosomes
might be attached to the
endoplasmic reticulum.
Some of them might just be floating
out here in the cytoplasm,
so that would be a free ribosome.
Free ribosome.
And even from the point of view
of the endoplasmic reticulum,
the parts of the endoplasmic reticulum
where you have ribosomes attached,
this is known as rough
endoplasmic reticulum.
It's the ribosomes that
are making them rough.
It looks that way in a microscope.
So I'll just say rough ER,
for endoplasmic reticulum for short.
And then you also have parts
of the endoplasmic reticulum
where you do not have ribosomes attached.
And because that looks smooth
through our microscope,
it has been called, you can imagine,
smooth endoplasmic reticulum.
There are things known as golgi bodies.
Once again, another fascinating name.
You gotta love these names in biology.
That look kind of like
an endoplasmic reticulum,
but detached from the nuclear membrane.
So let's say it's something like that.
That's my best drawing there.
That's a golgi body.
And these are really good
at packaging molecules,
even proteins that might've
just been produced,
and packaging them so
that they can be used
outside of the cell, for example.
And we'll go into detail in other videos,
where a protein might
go to the golgi body,
get a little envelope around it,
get some little processing going on,
and then make its way outside of a cell.
Now another,
and this is maybe one of the most famous
membrane-bound organelles
outside of the nucleus,
is what's known as the
powerhouse of the cell,
and that is the mitochondria.
So I'll draw this mitochondria in magenta,
because that's a nice powerful color.
So mitochondria.
And I love mitochondria
because it's fascinating
how they even came to be.
Mitochondria actually have their own DNA,
and all of your mitochondrial
DNA comes from your mother.
So that's actually very interesting
for tracing maternal lineage.
But mitochondria, this is where your,
I'm gonna say let's see what
we could see inside of this.
This is where you ATP is produced.
This is your mitochondria.
It's really the powerhouse of the cell.
What's interesting about mitochondria
is evolutionary biologists believe
that the ancestors of mitochondria,
because mitochondria have their own DNA,
they might've been independent
organisms, independent cells.
And at some point in
our evolutionary past,
they started living in symbiosis
inside of what would be
the ancestors of our cells.
And over time, they became so codependent
that they started to replicate together.
And mitochondria, in fact,
became part of these eukaryotic cells.
Now if this eukaryotic
cell was a plant cell
or maybe an algae cell,
you would have something
called chloroplasts there.
We don't have them because
we don't have photosynthesis,
but this is a chloroplast.
And if you could see inside,
you could see the little
thylakoid stacks right over here.
You could see the thylakoids
if you could see inside.
And so this right over
here is a chloroplast.
Chloroplast.
And this would be plants and algae.
Animals do not have these.
And these are where you have
your photosynthesis take place.
Photosynthesis.
Now there's also some
membrane-bound organelles
that are maybe less famous
than the mitochondria
or the chloroplast, or
for sure the nucleus,
and that might be
something like a vacuole.
And in plants, vacuoles
tend to be very big.
I could draw it, this is three-dimensional
so I'll draw it on top of
something that I've drawn before.
So if a vacuole right
over here, this is a...
And in a plant
it could be a fairly
significant compartment inside.
And in fact, it can even give
structure to the plant itself
because it is so big.
And it contains water and enzymes.
It's viewed as kind of
a storage compartment.
But it can also contain enzymes
that help digest things,
that help break things down
so that they can be used in some way.
So that is a vacuole.
And they don't just exist in plants.
They can also exist in animal cells.
But in plant cells, they can
be very, very, very visible.
Now, something that is somewhat related
to some of the function
that a vacuole plays,
that are most associated with animal cells
but now there's evidence
that they also exist in plant cells,
is the idea of a lysosome.
So a lysosome right over here,
that also is a compartment.
And it's going to contain a
whole series of enzymes in it
that is useful for lysing, you could say,
that is useful for breaking down
either waste products as the cell lives,
or even foreign substances
that might not be helpful for the cells.
So it's gonna contain a bunch of enzymes,
and it helps break down things.
Now, I'll leave you there.
These aren't all of the
structures in eukaryotic cells,
but these are enough of the structures
so that you can appreciate
that there are a lot of
membrane-bound organelles
in eukaryotic cells.
And to be clear, even if I were to show
all of the membrane-bound structures,
that's not all the complexity of the cell.
The big thing to appreciate
is that cells are incredibly complex.
There's all sorts of structures in here
that help transport things
and move things around.
If you could shrink yourself
down and look inside of a cell,
it would look more complex
than the most complex cities.
There's all sorts of activities,
things being moved
around, shuttled around.
The cell itself is replicating
and copying things.
And so this is just the beginning.
We're just starting to scratch the surface
of the complexity of the
most basic unit of life.